هذه المساحات التاسعه في شرق افريقيا
اختارتها شركه توتال انرجيس الفرنسيه
لاطلاق مشروعين بتكلفه عشره مليارات دولار
في المشروع الاول سيتم حفر اكثر من 400
بئر نفط وستعمل على انشاء اطول خط انابيب
نفط ساخن في العالم في المشروع الثاني
بحيث يعبر في تنزانيا المجاوره والعديد من
المحميات الطبيعيه
400 بئر نفط بينهم 180 في منتزه
احد اكبر واقدم المناطق المحميه واكثرها
استقطابا للزوار في اوغندا الاتهام
المجموعه الفرنسيه بعدم احترام القانون
يعتمد المحامون على قانون عام 2017 الذي
ينص على واجب اقاظه الشركات متعدده
الجنسيه وتحمل مسؤولياتها حول الانتهاكات
الجسيمه لحقوق الانسان والبيئه في فرنسا
والعالمه
يقضي واجب اليقظه الى وضع الحد الافلات
الشركات متعدده الجنسيات من العقاب اليوم
لم يعد بامكان الشركه الاختباء خلف
شركاتها الفرعيه وتقول لا لست انا انه
المقابل عليها ان تتصرف بالنسبه لتوتل
انرجيس يتم العمل لجعل المشروع مثاليا من
حيث الشفافيه والبيئه واحترام حقوق
الانسان لانه يشكل تحديا انمائيا كبيرا
لاوغندا وتنزانيا